hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that i stumbled upon
while browsing twitter uh it is a game
by the uh chess historian olympia urkan
and it's uh quite the attacking game we
don't know who he's playing against uh
has uh hence uh the the mr hoodie guy
here
and also why i am wearing a hoodie
hopefully you guys are as well in this
game
uh it's uh well it's so good that even
though it's only monday it's gonna
improve the
the rest of your week uh it's like you
know it has everything
and it's like completely no no reverse
gear morphy style uh brilliancy
and he said that he played very risky
when he was younger and
i imagine he still plays risky uh but um
uh well it cost him a lot of games but
it was
all worth it because he was able to
create one such game
uh for you guys to enjoy now so without
further ado let's check it out and let's
see what
this game is all about so olympia uh
with the white pieces opens with
d4 now we have f5 mr hoodie guy goes for
the dodge defense
we have e4 immediately striking in the
center also known as the staunton gambit
uh we have f captures on e4
and now knight to c3 uh developing a
piece while getting ready to capture on
e4 we have knight to f6
and now bishop to g5 so white continues
development we have knight to c6
and now uh dislodging this knight from
his natural habitat with d5 and this is
nothing new this has been played before
many times
uh there are over 600 games in the
database with this exact same position
so here knight to e5 this is
all theory and queen to d for now a
beautiful centralizing move with the
queen while attacking black's undefended
knight on e5 we have knight to f7
and here white has a couple of good
choices he could
capture on f6 he could develop the
knight to defend the bishop on g5
but here olympia chooses h4 so the
bishop is defended and you don't really
have the option of capturing this bishop
so if knight captures then we just
capture back
and this is game over the knight has to
move wherever you move doesn't really
matter
let's say bishop p2 and there is no
defense against the bishop to h5
you can never play g6 the rook on h8
would hang so
that's that's pretty much it so instead
after h4
we have g6 by black and now olympia
castle's queen side so
uh just getting another piece into the
game that is the rook on d1
uh and here uh there are some games in
the database where bishop to g7 was
played and this
is in fact the best way for black to
continue but here black
completely disregards any opening
principles and he
yet again uh moves the knight he plays
knight to d6
and now uh the position uh well
uh you know suffice to say has never
been reached again but
uh what what does this move do
here white has a couple of good options
but olympia
continues in the absolute best possible
way uh so the knight cannot move the
rook on h8 would hang
so h5 so what do you do here there is
no way for black to develop you really
want to play bishop to g7 and you were
supposed to play bishop to g7 a few
moves ago
and now black plays it but it doesn't
help black because here
h6 chases away the bishop back to f8
and you can't really do any discoveries
because there is no good jump with the
knight uh
so that doesn't really do anything so
instead bishop back to f8 and now
rook to e1 uh this is a beautiful
attacking move
in even though there are two pawns in
front of the the black king you'll see
that
this move goes a long way and now uh
it's hard
to make a move you you can't really
develop anything you can't move the
bishop
this knight cannot move because the rook
hangs you can't play something like e6
because then you
weaken the knight the knight is attacked
twice so here
black really has no good moves so here
black black could play something like
knight the f5
maybe uh to you know try and confuse
white but still it doesn't really work
for example queen e5
and now you could continue harassing the
white queen queen to f4 and now e6 and
it seems like
black is almost able to uh
well i would i want to say finish
development but it's actually to start
development
but here just bishop the b5 check and
that
there are no good moves here for example
bishop defense we're just going to trade
captures captures now we capture here
and that's it queen captures knight
captures on e4 everything is now hanging
you can't really move anything once the
knight moves its game over
there are too many pieces on that uh uh
well on that
e e file if you cast a queen set or
something like that just bishop captures
an f6 it's a free piece both of the
rooks are under attack they're
this is unplayable so even with uh some
sneaky defensive ideas like knight to f5
that the position is still
really really terrible however black
chooses a6 he decides okay let's just
take away that b5 square from white's
pieces
but now comes a a very a very cool move
knight to f3 so like i said this is a no
reverse gear game
offering a piece here not really because
you want to open up that e file but
black
uh once again for the lack of a better
move uh decides to capture this knight
it's not a good move but
there are no good moves in this position
so e captures on f3 it was played
but now of course comes queen captures
on f6
the e pawn is pinned so uh the queen
cannot be captured
we have knights to f7 now and what do
you play here
well uh like stein it's against bodily
but you just
free up the d5 square for the knight
okay i think stein is freed up the d4
square
uh but still you sacrifice a pawn to
free up the d5 square and bring another
attacker into the game
so here of course this pawn cannot
capture c captures was played
now comes knight to d5 and the white
pieces are closer and closer to the
black king
we have knight capture sun g5
eliminating one of the attackers but
here olympia doesn't capture back or
capture the rook here uh he just brings
another piece into the attack he plays
rook to h4 and now the rook can come to
f4 to e4
it all depends on what uh black plays
so here uh black said all right i
grabbed the piece uh he didn't capture
back maybe i can still do something here
he played rook to g8 uh
got the rook out of harm's way but now
it's actually a forced
checkmate in six six moves so feel free
to pause the video here
and try to find this elusive idea while
i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always
looking for that uh you know uh craziest
move that never works but here it does
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course queen to
f7
i want to do it in slow motion but it's
only one square so it's really not
possible but yeah queen to f7
and now uh nothing is defending the
queen and
it can be captured by both the king and
the knight but nothing works if the
knight captures then you've just taken
away the f7 square from the black king a
knight f6 is a beautiful smothered mate
a nice
fork smothered mate as the pawn cannot
capture and
the rook uh well the rook would the king
would be exposed to the rook so here
would be a nice modern mate
of course black did not capture with the
knight black captured with the king
but this also doesn't work that's why
the rook is already on h4 the rook lift
now comes into motion
rook to f4 with check we have kinked e8
this is the only move all of these
scores are taken if you see if you can
see this cover discovered by the pawn
this is covered by the rook so
you have to go to e8 it is the only move
and now comes the beautiful knight to f6
check uh the knight cannot be captured
as the e pawn is
yet again pinned so here king the f7 and
now
knight to e4 with check and again
amazing stuff now if the king goes back
now you don't repeat you go here knight
captures and d6
again a beautiful smarter checkmate uh
the the knight cannot be captured and
also the knight covers the f7 square as
well as delivers check on e8
so instead after knights the e4 king the
e6 was played and now of course the
finishing move the
hardest move to find is always with with
the knight back knight
the c3 a beautiful discovery this is the
only move that wins uh
you could try some other moves if you go
for example knight f6 check
then the knight can block with the
knight to the e4 uh but
um then then the king can escape for
example to f7 if
such a such a thing happens uh but here
after knight the c3
there is no defense and it was in this
position on mu21 that his opponent
who we know nothing about uh hence the
mr hoodie guy photo
resigned the game as uh there is only
one more move to make
the knight covers d5 the entire f file
is covered by the rook this is covered
by the other rook
so you can only give up the piece once
and then rook captures on e4 will be
checkmate
but after knight to c3 yeah mr kudiga
resigned and a beautiful beautiful
victory for
for olympia urkan for for everyone to
see
so uh as it was a quite a complicated
line i'm going to show it once again
after this rook the g8 so queen f7 check
we deliver uh this
beautiful queen sacrifice king captures
now we go into rook f4
check king has to go back now knight f6
check
we make uh sure our knight is nicely
transferred to e4
king f7 now knights the e4 with the
discovery
and like we said if here then here so
king has to go here and now
knight to c3 and that's it that's where
the game would end but here is where uh
black resigned the game so really a
spectacular attacking game i saw it
yesterday and
i was like uh yeah let's show it but i
couldn't
manage the time yesterday to show you
guys this uh beautiful attacking piece
so i do hope you guys enjoyed it and
that it didn't only improve your day but
maybe even the rest of the week as i
know you you're just waiting to show
this to everyone
uh your friends at the bar in the
library and you know just impress them
with
with your great uh choice of games
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
william gould mairesh modak cal stevens
frederick carragher
and tom todd modiset for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon by
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day